and so I told the story a couple months
ago and the person in the story had an
accent right and somebody caught me off
stage afterwards and they're like hey
you can't do accents and I was like why
and they were like it's 20 23 that's
offensive and I was like you should go
back to sleep
[Laughter]
but here's the deal guys can access be
a teller I think details are important
in my stories and if if your accent is
important to the story not gratuitous
but important to the story I'm using the
[__] accent okay
so I'm going to leave it up to you guys
you guys tell me if this story is
offensive I roomed with a guy who had a
lot of sex and if you ever lived with
somebody who had a lot of sex and you
didn't there's probably a chance that
you had to pretend like you were asleep
once or twice
so
my buddy comes in and I'm it's a Friday
night I'm already home and in bed and he
comes in and he's with his girl she's
gorgeous six feet tall
on the tennis team listen I know them
both still she's a wildly successful
woman she's incredibly smart one of the
funniest people I've ever met right and
they lay down in bed right
oh I forgot to mention she also happened
to be deaf Okay so
so
they get in bed and I'm no looksie Lou
dude that's not my thing and they're
over here you know dorm room the bed's
right next to each other and
I can hear them kissing just
and then I can hear clothes starting to
rustle just
and then they start to have sex
and I hear
um
yeah
[Music]
and I was like is that bed haunted what
the [__]
are they trying to find a whale on Sonar
over there
what is that noise and then it starts to
happen faster just
I'm like oh I don't like this I gotta
get the [__] out of here I don't feel
good about myself right now you know
what I mean and I try to get out of the
room when my buddy goes hey
don't go anywhere he goes if you leave
she's gonna know you can hear us and
she's going to get embarrassed and she's
going to leave and I go
don't talk to me
when you're having sex with her
and he goes just like this he goes she
can't hear me
[Applause]
so I go man I don't feel good about
myself being here
and I go can we speed it up he goes yeah
I'll speed it up I go I don't know what
that means but okay
and I turn back around guys I have the
pillow squeezed so tightly over my ear I
don't want to hear a thing but every now
and then just
would sneak through and I was like
um [__]
so finally I had had enough right and I
rolled back over to him I go hey man
how do we speed this up like
do you need me to blow on your [__]
or
for real five minutes a day is worth
this being over so tell me
tell me what you need you need me to
touch your button a couple times you
need a few Knuckles I'm here for you bro
what do you need from me
and he goes I don't know why this is
taking so long and I was like me neither
and he said maybe I'll see if she'll go
downtown on me that usually makes things
go faster and I go cool cool let's see
if we can make that happen
so I got my back to him again right and
I can't
it's quiet and I'm like oh that worked
and then a couple minutes later all I
could hear was him
and I could hear like his muffled
[Laughter]
and then this noise
[Music]
and I've got my back to him right guys
I got my back to him and I'm just
thinking to myself
well I kind of need to know what that
noise is
I wouldn't have forgiven myself if I
hadn't rolled over and just taken a peek
at one huh all right so I roll over and
she is going downtown on him right and
he's scooched up to the top of the bed
can't go any further and he's doing this
huh
and I just leaned in and I go
dude
what the [__] is happening right now
[Applause]
I'm just gonna tell you exactly what he
said to me because I couldn't write a
punchline that beats exactly what he
said to me he goes
she's so toothy
and I said what
he goes yeah I keep trying to tell her
to stop but she can't hear me and I was
like oh no
and he goes I tried to squirm out of the
way but I think she thinks I like it so
she clamped down I was like oh no
I said what are you gonna do he goes
turn your head you're not going to want
to see this which made me go what are
you gonna do
[Applause]
and I turned back just in time to see
this dude grab her by the side of the
head and go no
[Applause]
I like to smoke weed let's bring it
I like to smoke weeds
[Music]
[Applause]